[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily human
remains found in wyoming believed to be
those of gabby potatoes the latest
development in her disappearance as a
search for brian laundry continues and
the prosecutors rest in the federal
trial of r kelly where the case has
taken us so far and how the defense
pushes back as it takes center stage
plus a mennonite sunday school teacher
murdered and a united airman accused in
her death what you need to know ahead of
margu's arizona trial and later find the
defendant robert durst guilty of the
crime of first degree murder of susan
berman the trial is back and the verdict
is in what's next for robert durst as a
california jury convicts him of murder
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we begin with a story captivating
the nation the remains of a body have
been found matching the description of a
missing woman gabby petito this comes as
the fbi issues a search warrant at the
florida home of brian laundry spending
much of the day searching the family
home
laundry's parents were escorted out of
the home before returning inside for
questioning authorities say gabby's
fiance brian went missing last tuesday
on friday laundry's parents told the
police they hadn't seen him in days
florida officials then spent the weekend
searching for him back in july laundry
and potato left for a cross-country road
trip they documented their travels via
social media with the hashtag van life
on september
first laundry returned to his florida
home driving potato's van without her
she was reported missing on september
11th potato was last seen in late august
near grand teton national park in
wyoming over the weekend the remains
matching potato's description were found
in that same area an autopsy is
scheduled for tuesday
a family on vacation captured video of
what appears to be gabby petito's van
late last month in grand teton national
park law and crime's angel levy shows us
the video and what the family says about
it
jen bethune says that that white van
stood out to her and her family because
it had florida license plates and
they're also from florida but she didn't
realize the significance of the video
until a few days ago
on august 27th
2021
we got camera footage going through the
grand tetons
park
around
6 to 6 30 p.m
jen bethune narrated this video posted
over the weekend to youtube on the
family's red white and bethune channel
the bethunes drove through the spread
creek dispersed camping area they
believe the white van they saw was
indeed gabby potatoes we were going to
stop and say hi
because we're from florida too but the
van was completely
dark there was nobody there
fbi agents and park rangers descended
upon that camping area over the weekend
an area in wyoming that's part of the
vast grand teton national park
sadly on sunday the fbi announced a body
that matched gabby's description in the
camping area had been found although a
positive identification has yet to be
made
the fbi is not commenting on the bethune
family's video for law and crime daily
i'm anginette levy
thanks anjanette joining us today as
criminal defense attorney julie
randleman and terry austin julie a body
has been found should the authorities be
picking up brian
lawdry now or why or why not
so you know look i think it's a little
premature to pick up brian laundry at
this point again we don't know some
details we don't know if they're even
though we're waiting for the autopsy to
be done it is possible that there might
be signs on the victim's body that
indicate a cause of death and if it does
indicate a cause of death and that
points in the direction of brian laundry
then yes um
potentially we're looking to get into to
see mrs i think the big problem we all
agree on is
where is he um the fbi was not tracking
him he seemed to disappear last tuesday
there's been absolutely no sign of him
so yes we have to wait for an autopsy if
the autopsy comes back that she was
murdered then he may be very well the
number one suspect yeah interesting why
they weren't watching this entire time
especially up until this point uh terry
with a body matching description why do
you think the authorities are hesitating
to say it's her
you know brian they're being very
cautious here i think they know that
it's her but they do want to do that
autopsy first to make sure she's been
out there almost four weeks the last
telephone conversation was august 25th
and so we know that it's been almost a
month and the stages of decomposition
are four stages or five stages and at
this stage she's going to be fairly well
decomposed i'm sorry to say and they may
be having a hard time particularly if
there's nothing else at the scene so
they want to wait to make sure with the
autopsy
makes sense especially anything about
the timeline is when she was last seen
thankfully the family will hopefully
have some closure as this autopsy goes
underway
switching gears now to california as
harvey weinstein is back in court on
monday the film producer pled not guilty
to sex-related criminal charges
involving five women
weinstein's latest grand jury indictment
charges him with a challenge count of
sexual battery by restraint stemming
from a may 2010 incident this marks the
third time the prosecution has asked the
grand jury to amend the indictment back
in march weinstein was indicted on 11
counts involving five women weinstein is
due back in court on october 25th
the criminal case against the trump
organization continued this week as
former chief financial officer alan
weiselberg returned to court back in
july weisselberg pled guilty to an
indictment against him alleging he
participated in a 15-year tax fraud
scheme prosecutors claim weisselberg and
the trump organization engage in an
off-the-books payment scheme receiving
perks like an apartment mercedes-benz
car and private school tuition for his
children instead of compensation on
monday weisselberg's attorney said quote
we have strong reason to believe there
could be more indictments coming also on
monday a judge granted 120 day
adjournment
a deadly school shooting happened and a
colorado man was sentenced to life
without the possibility of parole after
that shooting in 2019.
on friday a judge sentenced 20-year-old
devin erickson who is convicted of 46
charges stemming from the shooting one
student was killed and eight more
injured after a then 18 year old eriksen
and accomplice alec mckenney opened fire
at their highlands ranch high school
mckinney told investigators he planned
the attacks for weeks after fellow
students made fun of him for being
transgender mckinney who was 16 at the
time of the shooting was sentenced to
life in prison but has a possibility of
parole after 20 years ericsson a legal
adult at the time was handed a mandatory
life sentence plus hundreds of years of
prison time handed down by the judge
still ahead on law and crime daily a
mennonite sunday school teacher found
murder and the united states airman
charge a look ahead of the trial of mark
gooch but first the federal trial
against r b singer r kelly how the
defense is gearing up as a state rests
his case
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live one
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back after weeks in the federal
trial against r kelly the prosecution
rests his case on monday
over 20 days in court the prosecution
called 45 witnesses many detailing abuse
from the famed r b singer
jurors heard testimony from the former
girlfriends accusers and former
employees some who were subpoenaed to
testify against him accusers testimony
range from upsetting to disturbing as
some women detail kelly's sexual
physical and psychological abuse the
prosecution alleges kelly used his
employees to recruit women to be used
for illegal sexual activities kelly's
defense fought back questioning why so
many victims waited years to report any
abuse kelly faces multiple charges at
the federal level including sex
trafficking and racketeering he pled not
guilty to all of the charges
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney julie randleman and terry
austin terry the prosecution has rested
but do you think there's more they need
to present to prove their case i think
they did a very good job they had a very
substantial case i mean it's been so
many days and 45 witnesses and there's
no question that they showed 11 victims
of the crime they had employees who were
there the real question here is can they
establish that rico charge and for that
they're going to have to show that kelly
headed up that enterprise and that it
was to establish sexual activity with
all of these victims so we'll see if
they were able to do that beyond a
reasonable doubt all right let's look at
the other side of it now the defense is
expected to put on a case is there
anything they can say to raise
reasonable doubt and should we expect
our kelly to testify
so we never know what's in the minds of
the jurors obviously but at the end of
the day i think what they're going to be
focusing on is trying to break down the
witnesses can they bring witnesses onto
that stand that will question the
credibility of the various witnesses
that testify because if they can and if
they're believable that raises
reasonable doubt in terms of whether r
kelly is going to testify i mean i think
we all saw the gayle king interview that
was an absolute nightmare and so no
attorney in their right mind is going to
want r kelly to take the stand but
sometimes defendants have a mind of
their own and at the end of the day look
at time will tell my expectation is you
will never see him on that stand
cross-examined by the prosecutor yeah i
would never put him on the stand and
julie i'm sure you would hide there but
at the end of the day it is the
defendant's right to testify so i don't
know anything is possible i'm hoping
maybe we can see a little bit more of
that gail interview on the stand but
we'll see how it plays out on to federal
court in california in the case against
elizabeth holmes a former theranos
employee testified that she quit her job
after holmes rushed the development of
blood testing equipment
on friday a former theronho's team
manager stated she quit her job in
august 2013 after theronos made a deal
with walgreens that would make the blood
testing device available to patients the
witness stated she was quote concerned
with the way the launch was going and
not comfortable with the plan they had
in place
founded in 2003 holmes claimed the now
defunct theronals would revolutionize
blood testing later investigators found
many issues with its programs the former
billionaire faces 12 fraud charges in
connection to her time with the company
the trial is set to resume again on
tuesday
and in colorado a trial is now set for a
man accused of killing his wife in may
2020. last week a judge ruled that the
trial of 53 year old barry murphy will
begin may 3rd of next year morpheus wife
suzanne morphiew went missing on
mother's day 2020. in a video barry
morphy claimed she was kidnapped and
begged for her return authorities say it
was an act and that he actually killed
her in in a ruling last week the judge
said the trial could go quote either way
meaning it's possible a jury wouldn't
convict morpheu of murder suzanne
morefu's body has never been found mary
morphy faces several charges including
first-degree murder and tampering with a
deceased human body
coming up on law and crime daily robert
durst found guilty of murder we
explained the conviction of the real
estate air plus a mennonite sunday
school teacher found murdered in arizona
and the finger pointed at a united
states airmen everything you need to
know ahead of the trial of mark goose
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
united states airman accused of murder
after a mennonite sunday school teacher
is found dead in arizona the trial of
mark gooch is expected to begin on
tuesday of this week ahead of that law
and crimes angela levy brings us up to
speed on the case
the body of sasha krauss has been
identified and located on january 18
2020 sasha krauss disappeared from her
mennonite community in farmington new
mexico 35 days later her remains were
found in a clearing more than 270 miles
away in flagstaff arizona her hands
bound with duct tape an autopsy showed
the 27 year old mennonite woman died of
blunt force trauma and a gunshot wound
to the back of the head prosecutors say
21-year-old mark gooch drove seven hours
from his air force base and killed
krause because of her faith and with the
help of surveillance video and cell
phone records they claimed to have
placed gooch at the scene
investigators say the air force airman
was raised mennonite but never
officially joined the church as for
motive text messages between gooch and
his brothers show disdain toward the
mennonite faith one brother pleaded
guilty to hindering the prosecution by
taking the suspected murder weapon from
gooch he was sentenced to three years
probation mark gooch is charged with
first degree murder and faces life in
prison if convicted for law and crime
daily i'm angenette levy
turning now to ohio where a jury is now
deliberating the fate of stanley ford
the man accused of setting a series of
deadly fires
closing arguments began on monday after
both sides rested their cases last
wednesday testimony lasted about nine
days as a defendant elected not to take
the stand in his own defense ford is
accused of setting three fires in his
neighborhood and two of which resulted
in the deaths of nine people one group a
young family of seven where all children
were under the age of 15. the jury will
be sequestered following the closing
statements and will be allowed to
deliberate until 8 pm eastern if ford is
convicted he could face the death
penalty the penalty phase would begin on
september 28th
another twist in turn in the murder
murder mystery just days before a botch
assisted suicide plan alec murdoch
refused the right to take control of his
late son's estate back in june mother
maggie and oldest son paul were found
murdered at the murdog family home in
south carolina at the time paul was
facing criminal charges stemming from a
fatal boating incident from 2019. last
alec murdoch admitted he arranged for an
assisted suicide plot all in the name of
a 10 million insurance policy he hoped
could provide for his remaining son
buster police say 61 year old curtis
edward smith shot murder on the head
though he survived smith was later
arrested murdo admitted to the plot and
turned himself in last thursday he was
later released on bond
a california mom behind bars this week
after she dragged her eight-year-old
daughter 300 feet with her car officials
say 44 year old erin garcia was drunk
and planned to drive away in an effort
to stop her garcia's daughter grabbed
onto the passenger side door handle
that's when officials say garcia
normally drove away her daughter was
taken to the hospital with minor
injuries garcia is being held on a
hundred thousand dollar bond
when we come back a guilty verdict years
in the making what a murder conviction
means for robert durst and what new
charges the real estate air could soon
be facing
[Music]
we the jury in the above entitled action
find the defendant robert durst guilty
of the crime of first degree murder of
susan berman
after months of testimony
cross-examination and back and forth the
verdict is in a jury finds robert durst
guilty in the murder of susan berman
durst was convicted of burma's december
2000 murder officials say he shot and
killed berman execution style in her
california home prosecutors say durst's
motive was that berman had information
about his missing wife kathy they allege
he murdered kathy in new york back in
1982 and that berman was going to come
forward with information on that case on
friday he was also found guilty of the
special circumstances of killing a
potential witness and lying in weight
more than 40 years after kathy durst
disappearance her body has not been
found and robert durst has not been
charged with that crime throughout the
california trial the 78 year old spent
three weeks on the stand testifying in
his own defense in just three days and
only seven and a half hours the jury
reached a guilty verdict durst was not
present for the reading of the verdict
because of a potential exposure to copen
19. sentencing is scheduled for october
18th
the jinx director andrew jorecki
appeared on good morning america to
weigh in on the role his hbo documentary
played in the trial it was drecki's team
that captured the infamous bathroom
confession in 2015 that set this trial
into motion
bob admits in the trial that he lied
five times perjured himself in this
trial he also admits that he lied in his
prior trial in galveston so you can't be
amazed by it but at the same time it's
it's very gratifying because you also
know this is a man who's evaded justice
for so long
that all you can do is hope for the
families of the victims that something
that they're not going to be surprises
andrew jarecki wasn't the only
documentarian following the trial
carrion folis host of the podcast jury
duty the trial of robert durst has been
able to be following the case he gives
law on crime daily his thoughts on the
verdict
i was absolutely not surprised by the
verdict um i think that
the prosecution
made an
excellent case they
kept in mind who their audience was the
entire time their audience was not
pundits their audience was not people
like me
their audience was those 12 jurors
the family of dirt's missing wife kathy
responded to the guilty verdict of
robert durst late on friday and are now
calling to finally bring justice to her
death
the mccormick family statement alleges
that kathy was murdered on january 31st
1982 saying in part quote more than ever
before it is clear that she was murdered
by robert durst and that the evidence is
overwhelming the family went on to say
how the justice system of los angeles
did his job and quote now it is time for
the westchester new york district
attorney's office to do the same for
kathy's murder the statement pointed out
that it was bizarre and unacceptable
that durst was tried for killing an
accomplice before he was tried for
kathy's murder the statement alluded to
an investigation by cold case
prosecutors that could include charges
against durst the westchester district
attorney's office says the investigation
is ongoing and they have no further
comment
julie the mccormick family has a point
durst was convicted of killing a witness
to a murder but not the murder itself
what can this conviction mean for the
westchester da's case
so here's the problem brian the the
first problem is you have a 78 year old
defendant who is medically without
question very ill that's the first thing
the second thing is very likely he's
going to be spending the rest of his
life behind bars due to what happened
with regards to susan berman
that's another factor and i think one of
the biggest factors that we have to
think about is when you're making out a
case the laws in new york are a little
different than they are in california
and some of the rules in regards to
hearsay that we heard time and time
again in regards to what happened in
this trial may not work in the new york
case and that's something that the d.a
must consider in order to make sure that
they can make out a case and make it out
beyond a reasonable doubt a lot of
moving parts there we'll see how that
plays out of course terry what do you
expect to happen on october 18th the day
of sentencing for robert durst well
brian we know that the jury found that
there were these special circumstances
under california law they found that
this was a murder of a potential witness
and they found that he was lying in
weight what that means is that he will
get life without parole under california
law and we know that there is a
moratorium in california as far as the
death sentence is concerned so he won't
get that unless something changes and i
don't foresee that so he's facing the
rest of his life basically in prison
yeah how long that would be i don't know
88 john lewis said he would outlive us
all so we'll see how that plays out for
robert durst as a sentencing comes up
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here at law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you